all right good afternoon everyone want
to welcome you to the first the semester
of the Yale AIDS quickly I'm series yaks
just a couple of logistical things that
folks have cell phones if you can put
them on silent or vibrate we appreciate
that we are recording this so that it'll
be up on our website shortly thereafter
the talk we are also working with our
collaborators at UConn's Center for
Health intervention and prevention so
it's being simulcast with them as well I
would encourage you to check our website
for further future talks it's WWJ led
you back / crc I are a today's talk is
co-sponsored by the division of
epidemiology of microbial diseases at
the Yale School of Public Health the
Institute for Social Policy Studies the
shell centre at the law school as well
as the global health Leadership
Institute and I'm going to go ahead and
bring a bar
person to introduce our speaker today
Michael fellow bloggers when it's a
pleasure for me to be here today my name
is Michael fellow I'm a professor in the
medical school but also director VL
world Fellows Program which is happy to
be co-sponsoring this event today for
those of you who don't know wanyan high
is the founding director of china's
first and i believe today the largest
NGO focused on hiv/aids this is an
organization whose name I certainly
can't pronounce but in English
translates into love knowledge and
action in really in many ways that
epitomizes what I've come to see in one
yunhai really is one of my heroes and I
think for many of the people in the room
is a shining example of the type of work
that we should be supporting especially
in parts of the world where it's not so
easy to advocate for human rights the
wine in Hajj organization is really a
very strong advocate for people living
with hiv/aids but also over the past few
years has embraced at the opportunity to
advocate for many people who are
marginalized for variety of reasons
whether it's because of their sexual
orientation their minority ethnic status
their substance abuse challenges this
group has really become an umbrella
group that's advocating for the most
basic human rights for many of China's
most marginalized patients so on yunhai
came to yale in 2003 he was part of the
second class of the yale world fellows
which is a evolved into yale signature
global leadership development program
this is an initiative that was launched
by president 11 in 2002 to create
essentially a cohort of future leaders
from across many disciplines whose
broadened perspective would be
influenced by an intensive academic
enrichment period here at Yale so this
program is really
an amazing example of yale's interest in
developing leaders from around the world
and especially people from across
regions disciplines and certainly
ideology so we are very proud of one
young high as an alumnus of the world
Fellows Program I encourage all of you
to check out our website and look into
the kinds of educational initiatives we
have her on campus and we are very proud
to have one yunhai back and also to
support him in his work in the future so
thank you very much so yeah welcome to
my you know lecture and a sense for
organizing the UN so so yesterday is a
you know China's in a medic autumn in a
mum festival so about 80 years ago you
know I was released from the government
detention center you know after four
weeks to tanjung so so a week later we
register our organization at the end of
ice in Beijing so before that the
organization is kind of you know not
where organized and in the video warrant
here informal networking you know and
also affiliated with a private college
but don't have a real you know
organization structure and the function
yeah
so the problem the project was created
in 1994 but they in general you know we
lack of you know a strong public
participation so but from 2000 because
of the blood scandal in China many
farmers who you know who soda blood
because of port he and many farmers got
infected and many orphans left by
parents who died of AIDS so the general
public become involved you know in
hiv/aids camp and so then a lot of
people we were called by people you know
all the time so then we had a chance to
organize people you know as a organized
in a group so so in 2002 we you know is
our transition period you know we study
the tool you know organized you know
people as one morgan alleging not
informal you know individual network so
in last year we had many difficulties in
before we register as an enterprise our
organization actually were banned you
know by security people you know
probably college you know access to
leave and stop our application in august
and sep tember we're at arrested for
four weeks so after my release you know
my colleague you know we decided the
tools you know our application of
register as an enterprise so on sep
tember 26 we submitted the application
the second day the organization where
you know the application will recognize
so when we register you know we have for
shareholders you know huija redone
prison and myself so huija is now in you
know in LA in jail and he was you know
arrested by Chinese government for in
advocating for blood you know human
rights and democracy and were arrested
in December 2007
like half a year before olympics you
know leaden is now organizing a new
organization treason is still an
independent you know gay film you know
direct so after my release I went to you
know America and yo you invited me to
speak in december 2002 len you know you
know Mike Muslim you know ding school
public health nominated me for a year
water fellow programs Soleil invited me
to give a talk about our work in China
my final comments is about you know in
our early stage we you know it's an
addict attitudes organization but when
government studied to tolerate in some
way when we study to provide a service
how can most activities to work together
so it seems like the first English up
shareholders you know divided and
Allen's separate so then we have new
shareholders we have for shareholders
when is a you know a lawyer working on
human rights issues when years on is an
environmental activist and when is a
lesbian activist so as a enterprise
register you know as an enterprise
register you know as a organization as a
non-government organization providing
you know Public Interest service patent
registers enterprise we are facing in a
meaning and difficulties many
difficulties so I spend a year nine
months in year and the first four months
in your China and then moved to you know
water fellow programs so by the end of
2003 I I slide it back to China and a
walk in China for more than six years
and my hair become Hawaii okay extremely
you know I worked really hard extremely
really difficult
in a moment so from early Lizzy I was
going to let him study to be correct
them again so our 16 year and it was
early you know conference were banned
and repeated the government you know
hajiman taxing was engaging a lot of
issues so in the first six months our
organization receive the pressure karate
man from about ten government agencies
in Beijing only in Beijing outside of
aging let some other government agencies
you know targeting on us but only in
Beijing will receive pressure from above
tango emerging with pleasure yeah so
today I'm going to you know reporter
back to each year about how you know
we're managing our organization in a
pasta you know six years so as a
nonprofit organization but the register
as enterprise we have two following two
standard we need to follow in both
standard for nonprofit and a standard
for profit you know organization so that
is extremely difficult and also we have
to work in both Chinese language and
also you know English so otherwise we
need to communicate it with our donors
so most of our donors are plum outside
from America from French from Germany
from you know united nations from like a
British government and different you
know donors so this is that we have to
work in you know bilingual we have to
following you know to standard so it is
seems like we we have to take a
labyrinth of to type of organization and
we can net we cannot benefit from either
side okay
so our location our main office is
located in Beijing so but we also have
some side of this in Beijing like we
have a drop-in center female sex workers
we have a you know site office for the
Wiggum you know my analogies for the wig
of migrants in Beijing we have a site
office for you know drivers long
distance drunk drivers provide health
education and some legal information
yeah incoming we have a branch office
and in quite insane young we had a
branch of this before inclement we also
have a you know a site office for drunk
drivers so but some of it you know we
are closed because of you know yeah so
maybe the problem not successful and and
now we are facing a you know funding you
no shortage of yet so the general
environment of you know working in China
is in a moment they were some tolerance
like it seems like in 2003 to 206
government the environment become more
tolerant but from later 2006 until now
the government study the to give more
pressure you know to you know NGOs and
angel we are targeted as you know one
potential risk you know forces which
causes and so from late before late
2000s six you know I I received phone
calls meetings from owning one
government security agencies and from
late two thousand six and I were called
by Modi girls ages and so in 2000's
seven the Beijing Public Security you
know Department the economy once a week
twice a week for meetings all the time
so it actually you know give me a lot of
pressure job
so but also you know in a pastor you
know six seven years we observe a rep
wailing rapid emerging in a sewer
society you know organization
development in alsa in all field not
only just on hiv/aids but in general in
all areas in civil society you know
organization become well it's strong and
also laser gluing you know you know
strong human rights movement so too so
today you know we you know everywhere we
see that the lawyers you know
intellectual petitioners you know people
belongs to like some you know religious
organization angels generalist you know
working really hard to protect the
people's right so compared with Nettie
nannies today is people tend to talk
about networking and a set of a network
so in meeting engineering when we
started to work on social you know
issues activists you know tend to not do
you know communicate and that active
tend not to narrow each other not to
have a meeting to avoid government you
know how lucky man to protect themselves
but today so you know activities NGOs
everywhere i use you know people are
talking about the establishing a kind of
alliance network you know let's type of
you know discussion yeah the government
civil society relationship is seems very
strange in theory with you know we
always see in a newspaper you know in
the academic articles you know so okay a
partnership between you know government
and NGOs is encouraging but in another
hand we always observe like that let's
state a security you know Department
Public Security Department you know and
also other maybe other government
agencies come and give you her regiment
and
skin area to report yeah so the United
Nations Global Fund are playing you know
active lure in China but in general they
are controlled by Chinese government so
in in China the UN Office embassies you
know international media all the
international enterprise when they
recruit in ER staff in a workers they
have to go through some government in
institutions that means that eventually
you know you n you know organizations
and have you know we're actually control
you know Pilar government so the meaning
international NGOs are working in China
but the most of them will self censored
you know they they tend not to work with
activist organization they mostly work
with government gave the money to
government or you know following the
government guidance yep so in a pasta
you know when I came back and started
you know managing our organization so a
color l'évolution heaven in Central Asia
then Chinese government study that to be
more suspicious against NGOs that is a
so this time you you know we always see
that it's a contradiction you want
analyze and laser you know emerging
rapid development also decided you know
another hand government is suspicious
government need NGO to help them in
service but then they are not happy with
NGO working on human rights and politics
so our administration structure is like
a shareholder jehudah as an enterprise
we we need for shareholders yehuda is
only for registration and a security and
find a regal alternative they don't
involve in a daily work they don't
involve in the policy directions so we
have a board of directors lady define
the institution policies directions and
we will the report yeah we we are you
know we are planning to set up
International Advisory Committee to give
us most important to nationally and also
help in fundraising yeah so you know
organization we have direct deeply
director director assistant accountant
program coordinate so we are probably
now we have about 20 people we used to
have more inner stuff more full-time
staff and more part-time staff and the
nationally we also give give support to
many more you know many grassroots
organizations they receive funding from
our organization so in our every month
we give celery to about you know 60 70
80 sometimes you can anything people
shall receive salary from our in a
financial department yeah so our men men
elder is actually aids prevention care
and advocacy you know legal aid but we
also work on discrimination against the
people with health problems like
hepatitis B you know carrier the
education rights walking Reitz in a
whiskey I'd be career and also we worked
on like abusing psychiatry against
ordinary people against the petitioners
against you know flip political
dissidents so yeah we worked on some
cases some really influential cases on
against us abusing psychiatry in the
last year so we also help you know set
up a group called patient's right to
protect you know like ISIL Pape patients
in hospitals
so our target population its most you
know imaginas population people living
with AIDS emo Felix gay communities sex
work drug users ethnic minorities
migrant and a young people here so we
work slow you know partners in the
networks so now we share in a very
strong partnership and gnashing white
almost half of China we have some
cooperation in so including like some
remote areli like Tibet and Xinjiang at
yeah ginger yeah we work with a gay
community organizations left so in the
past eight years seven areas we have you
know a surgeon have been supported we
have provided a real not just a
spiritual support we provided a you know
you know actual support like financial
supporter computers salaries for more
than you know 150 community-based
organization and a student groups that
some are pretty influential like Beijing
galliston center Beijing Olympian center
virginia Living Center is a legal legal
aid organization so actually it's
created from a program from of our
organization yeah so we helped set up a
national network of aids organizations
which now has more than 100 plus load
aids and yields all type of
organizations so Lisa's network is
pretty you know strong in 2005 we
already helped organize the National
Committee for a compensation campaign of
laboratory items but the least group
experienced many hajiman from government
so it does not work well because it's
like a lot of ecology many people where
they can shortly so a lot of pressure I
where they can for three days for
working on the compensation issues yeah
so I will work with people living with
days is more like you know mostly on
regulate full of blood victims but also
we work on the treatment education and
advocacy you know provide emergency you
know medical care support financial
support for AIDS activists who are HIV
positive polar hemophilia we also
provide legal aid yeah for gay
communities we actually provide you know
yeah so we provided in a really wide
early you know service like community
outreach in almost all sides parks bus
sex clubs in a bus house is some
internet social groups you know
promoting safe sex and nationally we
every year we provide you know we
provided half a million condomless
Republican for community organizations
to walk among gay communities so we also
organizing us sponsoring cultural you
know artistic you know gay lesbian you
know events like some pending
excavations and film excavation
producing from you know gay films like
that so we help you know like the gay
lesbian in a movement in networking
nationally internationally attending
international conference like that we
sponsor the two magazines when is a
national lesbian magazine called les
plus when is a you know gay magazine is
both our really popular in China okay
guess what solar novel a all both
independent but sponsored by Virginia so
for the sex worker you know work we
provide health care you know we pledged
occasion medicals here we have a part
time you know retired you know senior
you know doctor working on women's
health so lay with it you know in the
terminal place every week and also we
provide legal support for the sex
workers and whenever they work right on
the bag hour
by Allah place or some other inner legal
issues we provide in a support before
olympics where you had many training on
the legal issues can teach sex workers
how to face please haha she met before
Olympic around Olympics so yeah we also
advocated for visual illusion of sex
work in China enough and a provide
health service so every year we publish
you know human rights sex worker Health
and Human Rights report the last year we
publish the one and alyssia we are doing
to publish a new report you for drug
users we work in Beijing and none and we
so so let two groups pretty active on
Rodrigo a reaction when it is the blood
victims and other is the derivatives so
the drug we walk with drug users
organized many legal actions against you
know government on the plate abusing of
you know police power you know treatment
in a detention center and also like it
for a while you know financial aid for
the drug users yeah the capacity
building is about the you know help help
drug users to set up a little own
organization and a set of infrastructure
in a lower policy internal policy how to
how to run you know in organizations in
a open and a democratic away so that is
something we have done yeah so for three
years we have park we published the
human rights report about the drug users
in China for three years yeah so yeah we
are the report is going to be translated
by a year student song maybe probably
next month yeah for a wigger you know a
lot Muslim you know migrants so the
Muslim is the wigger communities is
really affected by drug use and hiv/aids
so among them my floating populations of
La Liga people nationwide there's a
really high in HIV in fashion valley
high extremely high yeah so if so about
the three years ago in beijing the rest
away
so among you know the wigger migrant
migrant population half over a doubt you
know I use we're using when injecting
drugs among injecting drug users one a
50-percent have been infected by HIV
AIDS and the typical osas and I hipot as
you see here as B is also a issue yeah
follow wiggle you know issues we started
to work with low we go you know
communities so health care health
education medical care if lo you know
service you know treat drug treatment
some people want to stop using drugs we
help them to you know yeah actually we
paid some people to receive drug
treatment in in the center so you know
because of social discrimination they
cannot you know find housing and the
police asked Earl Earl and a lot not to
provide a house for a wigger you know
Muslims so then we you know our you know
community workers you know visited each
families and a negotiated with the
police department to find a hot for the
we got people so soul is LA we go you
know working with the weaker communities
were thought about who has the most
extreme in a sensitive you know topic in
China so how can we work with the most
we go people which was sort of in order
you know media you know coverage we
wiggle people we are described as kind
of terrorists in China so it's a it's a
pretty sensitive topic but the butter
you know we are pretty lucky you know
compared with other topics we received
less government pressure on this topic
and I will receive more government
support on this topic okay so last year
early last year we allude a direct a
letter to her head of the police
department in Beijing and a criticize la
no discrimination against the Wiggles so
they were not happy but eventually
decided to listen to
my opinions and the government ethnic
affair Department studied it to call us
and ask us to provide information for
them and so and also let quarters to
establishing a cooperation so actually
the Chinese state a council estate
ethnic affair committee in a car in a
laser organization belongs to like a
Snickers a fair committee colors and
assigned a cooperation agreement and we
put a little name in front of our office
so our walk with you know the wigger
communities it's in the name of the
government not just the NGOs and the
last by the end of last year our program
working with the Wiggles were awarded in
wherein we received an award by a
relative range or Chinese media Chinese
magazine so every year they give a water
to like influential individuals or
groups working on nonprofit so our
organization in our work with Vegas
where you know where awarded in a less
the first award we were in China solar
state the state ethnic of their
committee also you know issued an
internal you know document send it to
the Central Committee the party central
committee and also tula beijing
government to the health department
supported our walk okay that is in the
past 16 years in our history this is the
only government agency who supported our
walking a written document okay okay we
have not received any official support
from a health department okay
so but unfortunately I thought in a way
we might receive more you know like more
government support so but unfortunately
you know we started to we begin to be
quick done by government again this year
and so so eventually I left it you know
I left you know China and with my family
and my colleague is still working layer
yeah so so we are now have another you
know transitioning period ok I hope you
know people here can also you know walk
with us on our transition period seems
like last year lat the summer you know
when government has studied to crackdown
against some legal aid organizations we
are working we were working really hard
to help to support you know those legal
aid organizations like one organization
supported by yo Jackie Chan Yeol channel
Law Center the open Constitution
initiative organization where band and
they were fined by the tax department
the head of law group were arrested so
we so we you know we are the first in a
person or going to let him stand out to
support them okay but it seems like both
in China and outside the China in both
government and the international donors
are changing are changing so last year
we are we also experienced some in a
change in a donor site so we you know
we're thinking about you know potential
dunno change and we will probably need
to develop a strategy to work with blood
you know donors and establishing our
public relations strategy and also to
responding you know domestically this
type of thing where we have been
discussing all the time last year so
yeah we had some important i doona
change and this year we had a funding
like we our founding decreases but we
lost about three million Chinese again
this year so but also in a sometime
government you know crackdown you know
against the earth so yeah we are now in
a pretty you know typical you know
situation okay